apple's privacy features that you've
heard about from their ios 14.5 update
are
costing
according to a third party service
facebook twitter youtube and snapchat
about 10 billion in combined loss
revenue in the second half of 2021
this is a story from the financial times
if you don't remember apple introduced
app tracking transparency back in april
as part of their ios 14.5 update i
covered that in episode 1204 if you want
to go deep basically iphone users are
opting out of being tracked this means
it's difficult to target advertising
from the big advertising networks the
big two where you know the majority of
advertising occurs on the internet are
obviously uh facebook and google slash
youtube
twitter and snapchat are you know minor
players in this huge advertising machine
that is the
internet but apple has stopped their
ability to target specific phones and
track you and retarget you and all that
good stuff that advertisers love and so
when users opt out of being tracked
it basically makes the cost go up
because you're going to need more
impressions and you're going to have a
lower click-through rate so the way
advertising works on the internet you
will pay
typically for each click that happens
and a click
for
an app usually a dollar or two dollars
in some cases ten dollars twenty dollars
for certain groups of users now who in
their right mind is going to pay a
dollar per click or five dollars per
click well if it's a video game that has
some kind of upselling in it or coins or
mono whatever it is
you know and they have whales in the
system who are spending a hundred
dollars on coins a month that means if
they spend a dollar
per person
to click and they get out of a hundred
people 50 downloads the cost per click
is a dollar the cost per download is two
dollars and then if one out of 50 people
spends more than a hundred dollars
they're in the black in other words
they're profitable and so this science
me is why you see certain types of apps
constantly being advertised to you on
facebook and other services twitter and
it's typically games that are the ones
that are really aggressive about trying
to get you to pay to get to the next
level
so
all of this comes from an ad tech
company i've never heard of called
low to me
l-o-t-a
and uh they note that advertisers are
responding by cutting spending
so we knew this would happen this would
be a big tailwind for apple in their ad
network because apple does sell ads to
promote apps it would be a headwind
against these large ad networks and
if you know more about the person you
can present ads to people
who are more likely to click what does
this mean there's a certain amount of ad
inventory on let's say youtube or a
certain amount of ad inventory on
facebook and instagram
if
you get one out of 10 people to click on
an ad
today and then tomorrow you get one out
of a 100 that means the ad network is 10
times less efficient
in other words you're using up
more of the impressions people seeing
the ad to get the same number of clicks
but if you know that your
app works really well with a certain
demographic
women who are 35 years old who are using
their who have these other apps on their
phone who have visited these websites
you get the idea
or this type of phone it might be that
people who have older phones really like
these bejeweled games it might be people
with the newer phones might really like
the first person shooters who knows the
algorithm is actually trying to make
sense of all this
and that's where all the gains in
advertising and the money printing ad
networks are getting their gains from
that's why google bought you know the
big ai company uh deep
mind back in the day it wasn't that they
wanted to win at chess or go those are
just you know shiny little pr stunts
what they really wanted to do was make
the ad network smarter and give you
better ads target them better so the
same amount of inventory would make more
money that's known as efficiency right
and that's why the money printing
machines of google and facebook have
done so well
apple
has decided we're going to
stop letting people target therefore the
efficiency goes down
and
according to low to me uh they estimated
that facebook twitter youtube and
snapchat quote lost 12 percent of
revenue in the third fourth quarters or
9.85 billion i'm not sure how they get
to that
financial times notes that may be
conservative they also know google is
not as impacted which is interesting now
why is google not impacted pretty
obvious if you think about it
google you type a word in a box and the
word is typically what you're looking
for right you don't search for something
you're not looking for type in volvo
you're not looking for chocolate chip
cookies and if you're typing chocolate
chip cookie recipes you're probably not
looking for a volvo
facebook and youtube create a
psychographic profile of you based on
your behavior
google
has that as well
but they know the keywords you put in if
you type in first person shooter or
angry birds or bejeweled we kind of know
that these games that are like bejeweled
we'll show you more of those right
pretty simple and that's why google is
going to not be as impacted by this
youtube will be but not google
uh so here's a chart for those of you
taking a look at the youtube channel our
youtube is youtube.com this week in
and if you go there hit subscribe and
then hit the little bell which is the
notification bell and you'll be part of
the nody gang notification gang and
you'll see when i go live i tape the
show live every day and a couple hundred
people watch it live so if you want to
watch this week's startups live go to
youtube.com this weekend click not just
subscribe but click the bell next to it
you'll get a notification once a day
when i go live uh which is kind of cool
so you can just see it here facebook was
the one that got murdered the most and
this is why facebook
is spending so much money on meta they
know that the next compute platform
apple is betting on is ar
that's why facebook is now
absolutely trying to
beat apple
at ar and vr
that is the big battle we'll see in the
next five years
compute went from being your desktop
then it went to laptops then it went to
phones and tablets next up social media
became a big platform the internet
before that what's the next one most
people believe it's
vr and ar i'm not going to call it the
metaverse it's kind of corny it's just
going to be augmented reality is the the
big one for me i think vr it's a bit of
a head fake
but yeah 8 billion lost by facebook
because facebook you don't type in a
keyword facebook needs to spy on you and
get all that data that's why facebook uh
is um
so good at targeting and became so great
and in the beginning we all know that
facebook wasn't going to work for
advertising because
algorithms weren't sophisticated ai
wasn't sophisticated 10 plus years ago
when facebook came out
so the ads on facebook used to be really
annoying and then slowly as they knew
your circle group they could say hey
people in your circle are clicking on
volvo ads
maybe we'll show you a volvo ad and see
what happens maybe your group is just
everybody's got volvo that's why
some people think that like devices are
listening to us
you ever have this experience
a bunch of your friends were like we
were talking about you know uh volvos
and
you know my friend saw a volvo on their
instagram the next day and so we know
that it was listening to our phones no
what happened was
your phones were all in the same
geography
your phones and your accounts were all
friends with each other and you comment
on each other's content
then out of your friend group of the top
100 people
seven of you
were talking about the volvo and you
search for it or maybe there was a
discussion thread about it the other 93
may have been shown the volvo ad
when the ai was testing
if these seven people in this tight
network are friends of friends
uh and you know maybe one degree or two
degrees
wow when we showed volvo ads another
forty percent of people okay so maybe
you live in the northeast maybe volvos
are you know the hot new thing you get
the idea so this makes you think that
it's listening to you when in fact it's
watching your behavior online and there
is obviously an overlap between the real
world
and
uh the digital world
if your bank charges outrageous fees you
need a bank account that's built for
small business you need to check out
novo's free business banking platform
novo is built from the ground up to be
powerful simple and provide free
business banking there are no minimum
balances no transaction limits and no
hidden fees that's why money magazine
called novo the best business checking
account of 2021.
novo makes banking easy and secure you
can manage your account in their
customizable website and apps and novo's
web apps have built-in profit first
accounting and invoicing you can easily
tag each transaction and upload your
receipts novo seamlessly integrates with
most leading business tools and services
like stripe shopify quickbooks and more
all for free and they also offer five
thousand dollars in perks and discounts
just for signing up so get your free
business bank account in just 10 minutes
at banknovo.com twist you'll also get a
novo debit card for free atm use and
you'll get a free copy of novo small
business starter guide that's bank novo
novo dot com slash twist one word
banknovo.com twist